all right let's shift the gears a little
bit and talk about something else many
of you have written to me and said David
I came in with a uh sort of open mind
and said I want to figure out on policy
do I agree more with Democrats or
Republicans great approach I think that
that's a worthy thing to do but then
many of you who write to me say
it doesn't really seem like Republicans
talk about policy anymore
like yeah if you look at a campaign
website you'll see a policy section for
a Republican and it'll include a lot of
buzzwords and seemingly kind of like
focus group paragraphs that don't really
say very much but when it comes to the
campaigns that they run
Republicans don't really seem to talk
about policy anymore and that's exactly
what I want to talk about today I want
to talk about how the Republican Party
has completely abandoned policy
it started before the Trump era but
acutely since the Trump era to the point
where now instead of actually talking
about issues that affect Americans lives
the Republican party has become focused
on grievances fear-based politics based
on lies about what Democrats or
immigrants or others will do and a
Resurgence in extremist social views
focused primarily on abortion and
anti-trans recently now let's start with
a recent example
after the 2020 election Republicans
refused to accept the results of the
election claiming that there was
widespread fraud they failed to win the
hearts and minds of the voters based on
policy and when they lost instead of
saying hey we're going to put forward a
policy set of ideas of pillars that will
be helpful to us in 2022 they spent two
years and now it's been more than two
years claiming that that election
actually was rigged that it was won by
Donald Trump and not by Joe Biden and
despite multiple
court rulings and recount audits they
continue to Peddle that lie and it is a
way that they make voters afraid they
make voters afraid and angry which are
the main emotions at this point that are
being utilized by Republicans to try to
convince people to come to their side
and that is at the core
of so much of the rhetoric that comes
from the modern Republican party another
example is the focus on extremist social
views Republicans have now become
fixated on pushing anti-transgender
legislation in multiple States hundreds
of bills arguing we need to protect
women's sports and we need to protect
kids in bathrooms and we need to protect
the Integrity of uh but I don't know of
we can't have drag shows because if it's
bad and they're obsessed with that stuff
all of it is based on false premises
like trans people are pedophiles or
sexual predators there aren't already
laws to protect against harassment in
bathrooms when in fact they are the
reality that the concern even around
Sports is a slice of a slice of a slice
of a slice of all that is going on
within Sports and it's all about making
people afraid and angry that people like
for example trans women who they say say
are really men are going to take they're
either going to take your child's
innocence or take your child's Sports
trophy or whatever the case may be fear
anger that's the person who I should be
angry at on immigration it's the fear of
supposedly lazy brown people leeching
off of social welfare programs but also
taking all of our jobs and that's always
a funny one these insanely lazy people
who are willing to abandon their
families and everything they know risk
arrest and death to come to the United
States
are then going to come here and work in
jobs that you would actually be working
oh that's very confusing but it doesn't
matter it's about the fear as Tucker
Carlson has said of people coming into
the country from Central and South
America making the country dirtier and
poorer and taking jobs and being on
social welfare and whatever the case may
be it's an insane uh juxtaposition lazy
welfare recipients who take our jobs but
it is about making you afraid and angry
at those people rather than at the very
corporations that have lobbied against
regulations which would actually punish
them more severely if they hire
undocumented immigrants and on and on
and on Republicans have also been
obsessed with cancel culture and
perceived threats to free speech and
again it's all about fear and anger
they're going to take away your ability
to even speak at a school board meeting
are they
or are they going to ask me to stop when
I've ranted for 12 minutes about masks
and I'm not letting anybody else speak
well it is true I've said before
sometimes there can be an overreaction
to someone's speech but for the most
part the issue of cancel culture has
been blown completely out of proportion
by the Republican party to distract from
important policy discussions I'm not
going to redo my segment on do the
victims of cancel culture actually end
up canceled the answer is no I've
already talked about that but the reason
for the focus on all of these fear and
anger-based elements is really easy that
there you know sometimes there's
questions in politics which are very
difficult answers
the answer for why Republicans have
abandoned policy is because Republicans
are losing most policy battles when it
comes to the American public the
American public is as against most of
what were the Republican policies today
than they have been for a period of
decades and decades and decades there's
so many examples of this a majority of
Americans support measures like
Universal background checks for any gun
purchase even in between private people
gun show whatever the case may be
most Americans support raising the
minimum wage most Americans support
addressing climate change exactly how
differs but most Americans support doing
something about climate change most
Americans support abortion being legal
in most cases most Americans now support
gay marriage most Americans support
using taxes on the very rich to reduce
income inequality
those are all positions espoused only by
democrats for the most part with a few
exceptions in the Republican party so
when you look at that and you realize
well Republicans are opposed to all of
that or at least they were when they
used to talk about policy all they can
do is focus on grievances fear and anger
and that brings me to the last part of
this which is populist rhetoric I've
explained to you before that populist
rhetoric is not a set of policy ideas
it's not like oh populism means a higher
minimum wage well it might or it might
mean keeping brown people out of the
country right populist rhetoric is often
used to pull people in and then you dump
the policy on them and the policy can
differ dramatically the populist
rhetoric is a tool that politicians use
to Rally supporters and usually there is
some bad actor right is the bad actor
corporations or is the bad actor antifa
well I don't know depends you know what
because sort of Point you're trying to
make and populist rhetoric can be used
to pull people into your movement
without actually talking about policy
the Republican Party
has been particularly Adept at using
populist rhetoric to appeal to its base
and much of that populist rhetoric uses
fear and anger rather than actual
proposed policy Solutions and so the
totality of this is that we've seen a
dangerous shift away from any
substantive policy from Republicans and
instead towards increasingly extremist
views on social issues and uh focus on
Grievances and a focus on fear-based
politics and scapegoating and at the
core it is driven by the fact that they
have lost the country on average can you
find anti-gay marriage people of course
you can can you find anti-abortion
people absolutely there's a ton of them
but at the top level it's a country that
has continued to move to the left
economically and socially Republicans
have lost that and instead of saying
maybe we'll revisit our policies maybe
we'll change no we will use popular list
rhetoric to make people afraid and angry
we won't talk about policy and when we
lose we'll claim we won and try to steal
the election anyway
extraordinarily dangerous but it's where
we are now as we approach mid-2023